my favorite uh kind of podcaster content
person
out there dm me and was like this is
this is this is a [__] great thread
and uh i was like blown away that this
guy wrote this and then
cnbc was like hey would you like to do
this some german news station was like
will you come on and talk about it
and i was like wow this is unbelievable
what could happen with just a random ass
tweet
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all
how many uh people did your tweet reach
how many people did my tweet reach yeah
so go to twitter and then click insights
and then look at reach i'm gonna guess 5
million
okay let's give it a shot uh so it has
13 000 likes
and yeah almost 5 million 4.8 million
impressions wow and
who all who are some of the more
interesting people who reached out to
you well first what
what did you what happened here for the
listeners okay so what happened
um i went on twitter and i
wrote a thread i wrote a thread about
clubhouse and the
thread starts basically saying you know
everybody seems to think that clubhouse
is the next big thing
and um i think it's gonna fail and
here's how i think it's gonna go down
and then i wrote it in this way that's a
little bit like
goofy i kind of went over the top i just
i was like all right you're the ceo
like first of all congrats champ you did
it you know and i
walk through like the high that they're
on right now because everything's going
great and everybody thinks it's the hot
[__]
and then like where things might start
to go wrong and what
what might go wrong based on you know
the way that the product is set up
the nature of that product and all that
good stuff and so
that uh that was a thread i put it out
there
and i thought it was gonna kind of flop
because right away nothing
happened and usually you could tell like
you know this you could tell pretty
quickly within a couple minutes you know
if the thread if your tweet's gonna get
any action or not
it didn't look like it's gonna get any
action then the first reply was this guy
being like
dude this is way too effing long like
what are you doing
and like the way he said like what i
thought i assumed some people would say
this is super long because it's like i
don't know 50 tweets or something crazy
um but when he was like what are you
doing i felt super embarrassed and i was
like [__]
let's just delete this this is stupid
and then i just like let it ride for a
few more minutes
and then uh it took off and now some
crazy shit's happening and like
i'm going on cnbc tomorrow to talk about
it and [__] so
all kinds of crazy stuff has happened
you're going on cnbc tomorrow
yeah i wonder if it's the same person
who invited trung on so you're the
second person associated with the
company who's
been on in the past two weeks i'm hot on
trunks heels i saw him on last week
talking about uh kathy wood and ark and
stuff like that and he was great
so if i can do half as good as he did
i'll be in good shape
and who else reached out to can you say
you told me a couple
uh yeah i mean okay so i can't say all
the names i'll say well
okay so first i started getting
mentioned uh by a bunch of cool people
so like
the guy who started youtube was like
dude this is [__] hilarious
like i love this and then uh so a bunch
of people who have started big companies
kind of were saying something
and i started getting dms from people
and and i kind of went to sleep
at first i was refreshing for like four
hours because i couldn't stop
uh like i was mid workout and then like
between sets i would go check my twitter
it was kind of annoying and
sony was like what the hell are you
doing like what is this and i was like i
don't know i'm obsessed i
i really just want to see it was like a
i would pull the refresh thing and then
a different kind of
famous person who i look up to was
usually saying like
this is awesome or something like that
so that was kind of addictive
i went to sleep i woke up the next day
and so in my inbox is
a offer for a book deal hey
uh like a famous movie director who
directed like a bunch of movies that
we've heard of
uh wrote like dude amazing storytelling
this is all i found my email address and
emailed me that he's the
uh i think i could say it he's the
director of uh like space jam 2
and like a whole bunch of famous movies
and then
um i i don't know if i could say this
one but
my favorite uh kind of podcaster content
person
out there dm me and was like this is
this is this is a [__] great thread
and uh i was like blown away that this
guy wrote this and then
cnbc was like hey would you like to do
this some german news station was like
will you come on and talk about it
and i was like wow this is unbelievable
what could happen with just a random ass
tweet like how is
it gonna take you to write not even a
good one really um
it took me an hour i sat down and so the
way this played out actually was
i had already believed this but i
thought okay
that's not cool like nobody thinks it's
cool to
just say oh a startup is going to fail
well most startups fail so like there's
nothing
that original there but because i had
built a product
very similar to club boss i kind of knew
what the challenges are going to be and
where they might get tripped up or
what's going to be really hard for them
and um and so i thought well i kind of
feel like i know the product strategy
here but like that's kind of a if i just
write about the product decision like
some of the product challenges and the
product strategy it's a pretty boring
tweet storm nobody's going to really
care
so when i ended up writing it i wrote it
like an episode of silicon valley
in fact ehrlich's ability to jerk
different dicks simultaneously
[__] yeah i think it would like the hbo
show like i basically wrote it in that
style like
i wrote like you know okay you know
emily chang
invites you on to you know whatever cnbc
and
to do an interview you know you wear
your your visionary
gray v-neck shirt you go on and you say
this this and this and so i was just
kind of writing like a goofy style i
wasn't just writing information i'm
trying to entertain a little bit
and uh and then emily chang replies to
the thing being like you know i can't
confirm or deny this but this is on
point
and um so all kinds of crazy stuff was
happening but yeah it took me about an
hour and then i just hit publish
and you got like 30 000 followers from
it congratulate or 20 000 maybe
yeah dude that's the way that twitter
works though is like you think
it goes against like all the
conventional good advice which is just
like you know be consistent
put out content all the time and like
you know try to like hit a bunch of
singles
and like what i found and i think i
don't know you tell me if you found this
too which is like
it's just like five tweets that grew me
from 20k to 120k
everything else was the cost of doing
business it's a it's the hits business
yeah it is and
uh so so summer summarize this actually
bray you asked me to ask you to
summarize this
the your bear case for clubhouse because
we're actually going to use this
probably for
one of our twitter videos okay all right
so all right so let me
okay we gotta we got we gotta we gotta
get the the video guys
video guys this is the part you're gonna
edit all right here we go uh
so everybody's saying that clubhouse is
the next big thing you're hearing about
it all the time they went
you know from a test i think they were
in test flight and they raised at a
billion dollar valuation which is kind
of crazy that apple's no
they were in test flight they raised at
100 million but it's right but now
they're at a billion dollar evaluation
it hasn't been long they're still
ios only still pretty exclusive you
can't even you can't even join the app
unless you have an invite
and so um but i see the other side of it
i think that they're gonna fail
i hope they don't fail i think the world
is more fun if they win
it would be awesome if they win but i
don't think
me wanting them to win doesn't mean that
that's what's going to happen i sort of
i said in the twitter thread i said you
know if uh if me wanting something to
happen would happen then every bag of
chips would come with guac
but that's just not the way life is and
um and so okay so here here's how it
works all right
pretend you're the ceo of clubhouse sam
you know first of all
you [__] did it you made it people
actually like the thing you made
and they don't like it they love it and
uh you know you check your dms and
chrysa is in your dms he says dude
congrats this thing is this thing is
kick ass
and you know naval is liking your tweets
and keith reboy is basically saying like
this isn't [__]
uh you know this is not garbage and so
you take that as a huge compliment as it
is
and it feels like every day you open up
the app and like a new
star is coming on the platform like
first kind of like just tech
dork stars like you know the market
andreessen's ben horowitz people that we
like but they're kind of niche in our
in our circles and then it'll expand and
all of a sudden you'll get
you know nba players coming on you know
famous musicians
logan paul will come on and then this
was the most liked tweet in the thing
was i said
you know gary vee realizes that you've
created a new place to yell
and he starts telling everybody hey if
you really want to make money go move
back in with your parents and sell their
furniture on craigslist
and uh so every life is good right you
get a term sheet you're valued at a
billion dollars and
you know you're doing interviews about
you and you gotta kind of ham it up
right because you can't just say
oh i made this app where you can go in
chat rooms and talk to people that
doesn't sound very
very fancy so you try to play it simple
but you talk
really fancy you say things like you
know this is like this is a serendipity
network
this is this is not not just chat rooms
this is audio escapism
this is you know when you start saying
like historical [__] like you're like
you know
humans have been talking to each other
since the dawn of time you know around
the camp you know
around the campfire and you know audio
is so powerful because you can see your
your tone and texture and um and so
you're going on the media tour and then
like you get back to your computer one
day
and you look at the charts and you know
the graph doesn't look as
you know as upbeat and to the righty as
it's supposed to be and so you're like
what's wrong with this thing you refresh
and it's still
the you know the growth is kind of flat
maybe even declining and you
you start to look a little deeper and
what you'll find if you're the ceo of
clubhouse is
after about you know a year into the
product you see that retention is not so
good it's not as good as it used to be
in the early days and
you know why is that the case and and
what will happen is that you'll realize
that
clubhouse is used for two totally
different things there's two ways that
clubhouse can be used
if you talk to users or you watch them
you'll see these two things number one
it's a place to create content and
number two it's a place to just
chill just to go hang out with other
people and have conversations
and so content is what we see all the
time on there it's panels it's fireside
chats q a's amas
and it's like oh this is content it's
like the next youtube it's where you go
you make
you make content people consume it um
you know and the problem is that
a lot of the content like on youtube is
just like meh you're right 98
of the content is junk and that's okay
that's the same for every platform you
just need to find that gold and there is
gold on
clubhouse right if you watch the good
time show or the the nyu girls who go on
there and
they have that show called shoot your
shot and that is gold but
um you and so you want to triple down on
that you're like guys this is what this
is what we need to double down on how do
we make this how do we get more gold
content
and you tell the whole team we're going
to go get more gold content and so the
engineers they go start building
features for content creators they build
like a scheduling feature and
q a tools and like a monetization
features where you can make money from
your fans
and the creators are happy but the
retention stays bad and
what you realize when you talk to
somebody who knows what they're they're
talking about here is that
there's this like problem called the
interestingness problem
which is that when you open up an app um
there's one metric that matters called
ttf
and ttf is time to fun how long does it
take me to have some fun inside this app
get some dopamine and all the great apps
within seven seconds if you open tick
tock youtube
instagram in seven seconds you're gonna
get something juicy you're gonna get
fun and um and you know the way those
apps do it is they have billions of
pieces of content to choose from and the
algorithm knows okay this is the most
liked content
the last 24 hours so it shoves it in
your feed and when you open the app it's
going to show you something
great right tik tok calls us the for you
page because it's here's the best stuff
for you
and that's why tick tock is so addictive
every time you open it you get something
great
but for clubhouse you know you tell your
engineers hey that's what we need make
an algorithm that will do that
and the engineers you know they sit you
down in a chair and they'll say
okay we're gonna do our best but just so
you know it doesn't like
it's one thing to just find what's
interesting but we have to find what's
interesting and is being created live
right now
and when you multiply those two things
together it doesn't become twice as hard
it becomes
200 times as hard to find interesting
content when you open the app
and so the what happens is most people
will download this app they heard about
clubhouse they heard it's cool
they'll open an app and whatever's on
right then they'll walk into the first
room
and it'll be kind of boring it'll be
kind of meh and then they'll walk into a
second room and then within 30 seconds
like why the hell am i here this app is
stupid they'll close the app and they'll
probably never come back
and so they'll get a bunch of downloads
a bunch of signups and then but they'll
all just be leaking out the bottom of
the bucket
and so um you know you're the ceo and so
you're like oh
okay yeah live is harder i get it but
twitch did it
twitch is live and look at that they got
you know hundreds of millions of users
so
clearly it can work you guys the
engineers you guys just need to make it
happen
and then you know the product manager
the engineers will come back to and
they'll say well twitch is a little
different right because
on twitch the great content creators are
creating about 40 hours a week of
content they stream every day six to
eight hours a day
and um they're playing a game so they
can do that they can play a game for six
hours straight just talk while they're
doing it
it's hard but it's not anywhere near as
hard as just
opening clubhouse and being entertaining
for six hours straight while talking
maybe some radio hosts can do that but
the average person cannot
and um and then the second thing they'll
say is like also you know
almost all the content on twitch is
about gaming so
as a viewer if i come on there maybe one
creator's not live but another fortnight
creator is live or another fortnite
creator is live
it's like density around one passion
whereas clubhouse is every category some
people come there for music talk some
for sports some for tech and so if i'm a
sports person and i see a tech room
that's of zero value to me
so twitch is vertical club is horizontal
this is
gonna be really hard to get great
content in every category
and so you know i kind of fast forward
and you know okay this is tough
and um you know your meeting ends the
next meeting engineers leave next
meeting
is the biz dev guys biz dev guys come in
and the biz dev guys are like
you know what do you want us to do boss
and you say you need to go get great
content go get all the stars we got all
this money in the bank go go pick cut
some checks
let's get some star creators on the
platform and you'll go to people
um who have who have a big audience who
go to podcasters right you go to people
like us
and we're gonna say okay so if i could
spend an hour on clubhouse and get
i don't know 2 000 3 000 people in the
room that's good right but like
if i just record a podcast i'm going to
reach 300 000 people with that
so why am i why would i ever make this
trade why would i go live here
when i go live there right when i could
just record my podcast
so you're the ceo you say all right
that's a tricky problem but maybe you
could do both right why do you have to
choose
do your show live on clubhouse and we'll
add a recording feature
so that you could just make a podcast
out of it later you can have your cake
and eat it too
and so you do that and some creators
start to use it but um you realize
there's a big problem with that
which is as soon as you start to like
let people record
and the core thing becomes i'm recording
my podcast here i'm just doing a live
version that will turn into my podcast
or turn into a youtube video
well then this live thing becomes a
second class citizen and i stop
letting guests hop on my clubhouse room
and chat with me because i don't know
what the hell they're going to say it's
unpredictable
and you know what makes for a great live
session is that spontaneity
but that makes for a shitty recording
and so um you know that's
that's another trap there so okay you
finally you have an emergency team
meeting you say this whole content thing
sucks um you know we we only have a few
pieces of great content only a few hours
a week for every vertical this is going
to be impossible to do in every category
that's like recreating all of tv and
that's just really hard to do
um you know and and i'm tired of all
these people on there doing shows and q
and a's and these success coaches trying
to
manifest millionaires and all this
[__] you know what is this discord
for douche bags like
screw shows we need a new plan and we're
going to plan b plan b
is chillin right this is a social
network it's not a performance network
you come here to socialize you come here
to just talk to other people
that's the most human thing in the world
seven billion people on earth talk to
their friends
this is what you know this is what we'll
do here um and you know you you you ask
people who had a great experience so far
in clubhouse the people who think it's
amazing
like our you know our friend narendra or
you know bit different people who have
really enjoyed their experience and
you ask them why and they'll say well i
came on
and i was i was in this room where this
really cool thing happened and mark
andreessen was there and then this guy
was there
and then you know i went into a side
room and i met a bunch of other cool
people in the tech world and
we got along great i made a bunch of new
friends and you say all right that's
what we're going to do
and um and sure enough that actually
solves your retention problem because
people will come here it will solve
loneliness people will come here they'll
hang out and they'll make friends
but all of a sudden your growth will
stall right because if i'm coming here
to make friends and i'm not bringing
friends to the platform
that's kind of the the rub there right
so any platform where the value prop is
to make friends
i'm not gonna bring friends so now you
have sticky retention
but now you have no growth and in the
other world you had fast growth but no
retention and so you're stuck in this
catch-22
and um you know so then you know just to
kind of round it out you
eventually get disillusioned you realize
this shit's not gonna work you try to
pivot
you eventually sell the company to
facebook you spend a year as the manager
of facebook voice
and uh then you quit you go you travel
in southeast asia for a year you do some
ayahuasca
and you vow to yourself i'm only gonna
ever work in enterprise sass again
you know screw this social thing and uh
so that's my story
uh over the top i hope i'm wrong but i
think that's how it's gonna play out
and i think a lot of people who are
hating on you didn't realize that this
is the life that you led
yeah yeah some people are like wow
that's really detailed where this
where's this coming from and some people
are like dude that's way over the top
and i'm like dude i built this before
like we built a app so similar to this
it grew to four million users and
tony robbins was using it an espn was
using it and the jonas brothers and then
oracle was using it and then
you know some of the tech guys and the
37 signals guys were using it and it was
awesome product
was using it and then we hit the you
know we get to 4 million members and we
just started to see these same issues we
tried everything
to fix it and i hope these guys find the
solution that we missed or maybe
the world has changed or there's some
differences but the reason i
you know this was 70 my experience 30
percent
you know fantasy that i wrote this thing
with i guess uh
we're gonna have to check in on this
podcast in like maybe one year i bet i
think we'll see how things shake out in
about 12 months
yeah and i guess like the more
interesting part that i wanted to talk
to you about was
okay so first of all creating something
that goes viral is such a crazy feeling
and
you've done it a ton i mean you built
the hustle with a bunch of
really viral blog posts like this is
kind of nothing in comparison to the
blog post you guys wrote
and also you're a writer so you kind of
have a process where you sniff out
stuff that you think is gonna go viral
whereas for me i'm not really a writer
this is kind of me
just trying to i mean you you you have
the it factor i think that um
i think you can study and how to do it i
think that you can just be
born with the skill set um i think you
and i are quite similar in that it's
both
born or we we have that natural gift
and also we learn and master the craft
right
i think you've tried it a lot more and
therefore your hit rate i think is
is higher i personally i just think that
but um the question i was going to do
i mean dude you got to 120 000 followers
on twitter in like
basically six months yeah that's true
um so i wanted to share so when i uh so
the way this this came about
because i think this is ultimately more
interesting right the rant is kind of
interesting but
the how this happened i think for people
who are listening they'll probably find
it
i think they find it interesting um the
way they started was a pretty
high profile vc person called me one day
i had never met them before they had
said oh you seem interesting on twitter
i'd love to meet
so we did a phone call and then we were
talking just about each other's
backgrounds it was cool and then
they were like well what do you think of
clubhouse by the way i gotta ask
and um and i think they asked us because
they had looked at investing they
ultimately didn't invest and they were
trying to figure out like
am i gonna kick is this gonna be is this
gonna haunt me you know for the next
five years that i missed this deal or is
this gonna be
a good one and um you know a good pass
and i basically
i i just went on this rant on the phone
about this it just kind of came out of
my mouth i like just the way i kind of
explained it here and um
without the whole like kind of
dramatized like
tv show script but just the reasons why
i think it's gonna
struggle and um and they were like wow
that was great like that was amazing and
i was like [__] i should have wrote that
down that was like
that would have um i feel like that
would have been like a good
like piece of content and so i went i
kind of like quickly was like i gotta go
and i hung up the phone
and i went to my computer and i just
typed the whole thing out
and um and it turned into like and then
i was like okay whatever i i kind of
edited i took it out
i did your your tip which i took a break
for an hour yeah just when it went and
did something else
came back and i edited it for about 30
minutes editing
is the magic to everything it doesn't
matter you're talking about a viral
tweet
a good email editing is the magic they
say write drunk edit sober
oh that's a great one i've never heard
that i love that um i think you're in an
attempt
to just i used to just edit in the
moment like i'd write no no no
no and that was a mistake the tip you
gave me a while back was
go do other [__] let it simmer in your
head while you do other things don't
even actively think about it by the time
you come back you can make it twice as
good in 20 minutes
yeah and there's actually some science
behind it i i i can't tell you the exact
science off the top of my head but
basically
you know how there's like a shower
thought of like not doing it so there's
like science behind like doing something
really hard and then not doing it and
then things hit you
uh there is science behind why that
works and that's kind of what you're
doing
yeah basically like the brain relaxes in
some way and then when it relaxes it's
able to be
creative in a new way and so um okay so
then i post it and then
whatever you know [__] as well so then
uh so that was that was oh sorry the
other part that i forgot which i think
is
my new it's something i've been doing
and i'm curious if you do something like
this
before uh before i write anything now
at the top of every page i have a
template and at the top there's like
seven lines that says
what reaction is this meant to get and i
have seven emotions it's like
lol like this is meant to be really
funny is it
wtf where it's like dude what the [__]
and that's when you're talking about
something that's really unjust
or people are pissed off and you want to
you want to explain hey there's this
really messed up thing that's happening
and people be like oh my god
um then there's other ones like you know
like aw aww something really cute awe
oh like like that something is awesome
like wow that is like kind of amazing
wait did i tell you that i do this no i
actually learned this from these other
guys who make viral videos
rubber republic they had a search engine
where you would just search by
one of these emotions and it would pull
up viral videos that had that
that were based on that emotion as well
so the way to go viral is you always
want to start
you start with the emotion that you're
trying to get out of someone um and you
and we already know that certain
emotions get more shares
so for example creating depression or
sadness that doesn't get shares
um creating outrage gets far more and
with small tweaks you can make something
sad
outrageous and that's far better right
you know so it's either amazing it's
super funny
it's really really outraging it's um
it's really touching and heartwarming
that's another one hard to do and then
the one i had for this which is kind of
like a new emotion which was
i wrote finally someone said it
and i actually think that's a that's its
own genre that i didn't even have in my
template
because i was like i think this is gonna
go viral but it doesn't match any of
these
i was like i think for some people it's
gonna be wtf like dude this guy's a jerk
why is he predicting failure what an
[__]
but i thought no it's gonna go viral
because if you say something that a lot
of people have been thinking but they've
been afraid to say
or they couldn't put words around it
exactly but they had this hunch
they will share it because they agree
with your opinion
for them it's the idea of recognizing
something that you feel that you weren't
sure if other people feel but you see it
on paper
so the same example is with location so
when you see
like uh how you know you're a san
francisco bro or how
do i know uh do you know sean perry like
if i said if
i saw an ad that said do you know sean
i'd be like oh wait that's directed just
towards me
right so with the emotion that you just
evoked was like finally i didn't think i
was the only one who thought like
it's a recognizing it's it's a
recognizing something type of
vibe and they're really sharing because
they're like i knew it
i i'm right so they're not saying wow
he's so right they're actually saying
i'm right read this this proves i'm
right which is like a real subtle thing
but i'm so
interested in studying the like
psychology around
why people do what they do why do they
share what they share
because i want to grow an audience and
this is the best way to grow it and
i feel like this i'm this process that
i'm doing i'm so glad you said you do it
too because i thought i was a little
crazy i was like no that's what we used
to do i mean that's what i do when i
i'm like i i i start with the emotion
then i start with
the package like how am i packaging this
then i start with the headline
then the preview image and then i work
backwards from there right
and i always try to find like i'll find
something that catches my attention just
one fact or one line so for example
um i was just doing research on one
yesterday do you know um what recaptcha
is
you know like um when you're signing up
for something
you're signing up for something that
says spot right nowadays they say like
spot click the thing or type in the uh
the
whatever picture is a sign click it yeah
it'll be like you know where are the
traffic
lights click all squares with traffic
lights and uh
by the way this is a good example i saw
this meme that was that recaptcha with
the traffic lights and in one of the
squares just the tiniest corner of the
traffic light is in it
and it shows the guy like suit like
sweating like crazy like oh [__]
should i include that or should i not
include that and that's one of those
where it's like me too
dude i have i almost feel that way i'm
always confused by this thing
that's just supposed to so i always feel
that way meme
now here i can take it another way do
you want to know when i looked that up
on wikipedia you want to hear a fun fact
do you know why they do it this way is
because
people like google um i might be
butching this just a little bit but the
idea is the same
people like google are paying recaptcha
to translate
stuff so for example somehow picking out
that sign
or saying where the headlights are that
actually helps google and google's
paying you money
it's painful i have a little so the
original captcha was
done by this guy he was a professor at
duke and carnegie mellon and captcha
originally was
letters remember it was always these
kind of script like kind of hard to read
letters but you could read it
and that was basically taking they had
scanned a bunch of book pages
but who's going to conv the computer was
not good enough at tr
getting all the book pages to translate
over to text in the computer because
some of the book pages were a little
rounded or wrinkled or kind of fuzzy
and so the computer couldn't do it but a
human eye could easily do it so they
basically outsourced the work and solved
two problems with one stone
on the website side they just want to
make sure you're not a bot who's signing
up for their service
like a scammer who's going to spam
everybody but then
they did good in the world also because
that project
ended up transcribing like millions and
millions of books i think all the books
that they had
scanned eventually and then capture two
is about a recaptcha
i believe is about image classification
so for self-driving cars we need to know
is this a bus or what is this and so i
think that's where the original
idea was uh classifying images let
humans do it
while they sign up and the inventor of
recaptcha the second one his name is
luis von on
i think that's how you pronounce it he
did both and that guy started duolingo
and when he started duolingo he started
it for two reasons one he i guess he
just cared about
helping you learn language but two when
you are
learning the language you're actually
translating stuff
that a third-party service is paying for
you to translate
so that's crazy so what a genius the
exact
emotion that you just had of this guy's
crazy that is the mo
emotion wow this guy's a channel i am
trying to evoke by
sharing that so i can tell that story
and probably five tweets and i bet
it will like virality is pretty
impossible to predict
but i can bet that there's like a three
out of ten chance that it's going to
that has legs i could say this has all
the
uh this text is all the box to get
popular i can't
i can't anyone who says that they're
gonna be able to predict it they're
wrong like shawn's thing just reached
five million people he was like this is
not going to work
the other part you had there that was
good is that you took a thing that we've
all seen it's a relatable oh yeah i've
filled one of those in and you
so you took a very familiar thing but i
told you the uncommon truth around it
um which i think is like really cool
like there's one yesterday i saw
uh you know tom cruise's name is not tom
cruise his real name
no what is it it's tom uh tom cruise
something it's like his middle name is
cruz and his last name is like some
uh like very look it up it's some like i
don't know random ass like name
and he changed it to tom cruise which
sounds like a total movie star name
makes total sense that he did it
and um so yeah his real name is thomas
cruz
mapothere the fourth or something i
don't even know how yeah i can't even
pronounce that
mapathar yeah tom mappather versus tom
cruise
and so you take something really
familiar we all know tom cruise right
boom here's the uncommon did you know
and then it's like
oh sweet like wow you know and that one
doesn't have as much shock factor so it
won't go super viral but it'll get a lot
of likes
but you know the closer you can get to
that
the surprise gap between what i thought
i knew and what's real
the more shares people will get yeah i
think if anyone cares about this stuff
i like the book made to stick and i like
the book contagious by jonah berger
contagious made to stick is how to say
something so people remember
and contagious is a great book by this
wharton professor on how to make things
get popular
how to make them spread like a virus
hence contagious i like it
you want to talk about paid newsletters
really quick a topic that we've
discussed a lot
yeah let's do it but this one is
particularly interesting
um the reason why is we've talked about
this company a lot agora financial i've
brought it up to you a ton
they spun off a couple of their brands
and they tried to do a spack and when
they tried to do a spec the company that
they were spacking with
just like kind of like went down like
dropped like significantly
so they there was already a publicly
traded company that was going to buy
a few agora brands the stock went down
big time
but that's not that important what's
important is the numbers behind this
paid
newsletter business so there's this
company called um
actually i don't know what they call
this little it's a subsidiary of gordon
of agora i think they call it beacon
hill it owns
six sorry 12 different newsletter brands
collectively
those newsletter brands do
where did i put the number 550 million
dollars in revenue
and 200 million dollars in profit and by
the way growing some that grew 77
percent
over last year is that crazy now i'm
going to tell you all some more numbers
they have 10 million free subscribers so
kind of like the hustle that's like
they've got 10 million of that
uh this is even wilder they have 550
000 people paying them six hundred
between one dollar and six hundred
dollars
for subscribers then they have a quarter
of a million people paying them
six hundred dollars to five thousand
dollars and finally
they have a hundred thousand people
paying them more than five grand for a
product for a paid newsletter
and what is in this paid newsletter
what's the what's this
way here's where things get way crazier
they have some paid newsletters that
cost thirty five thousand dollars
now the reason why what gets crazy what
gets crazy with this is that
they have a 160 products across 12
brands so what's that math so
each brand has uh 12 12 or 13 uh
products and the products i don't even
understand but basically i
understand the business model the
business model as they get you to buy a
50 or 49
thing then they get you to buy a 2 000
thing
and they're and so they get you to buy
that 49 thing and that 49
thing is like a monthly paid newsletter
like it's not significant right
i don't understand how they get it to
work and a large percentage of those 49
people buy the 2 000 thing okay so but
i feel like okay so these must be b2b
newsletters right
no they're not uh yeah that's an
important part that i left out
nearly all of this is around and we'll
link to their deck so they have a whole
deck when they
they it's kind of scammy so they it's a
financial and a wellness
company which is kind of weird they're
talking about health and they're talking
about wellness and if you click agora up
there sean under my name you'll see the
deck
they say that their their target
demographic is
self-directed investors what's that mean
well i'm going to tell you if i look at
the website it's just a bunch of old
kind of wealthy white people who are
probably republican
and because the reason i think this is
they have ads that say like nancy pelosi
is coming for your guns you better
invest in these eight stocks
like they think like crazy [__] like
that right it's basically the like
motley fool
on uh you know steroids right
yes uh but i think motley fools ethical
these guys aren't they
also sold a book on how to cure diabetes
okay
i was going to ask you why do you think
they're unethical and then you answered
my question
and so it's all financial news financial
newsletter
financial news related stock picks and
it's just
just a crazy story i've brought this up
tons of time we don't spend too much
time on it but it's pretty
wild to actually see these numbers i
actually guessed
that this is how big they were now we
have proof
yeah you've been talking about agora as
like you know doing hundreds of millions
of dollars and
you know some people know about them but
i would say most people don't know about
this empire
and most people i mean this blows away
most people's expectations of
you know paid newsletter right like oh
you know like i just had a paid
newsletter as an individual right i made
you know
a few hundred thousand dollars total and
i thought i was crushing it and these
guys are making hundreds of millions of
dollars so when you look at this
is my honest my honest reaction is dude
why couldn't you have done this with the
hustle why
what what did they do or what was that
why was the hill
too hard to climb where you could scale
like this because this is huge
i don't think it was too hard to scale i
think i could have done it
i would say that this business has been
around since the 70s
right so it's kicking ass now it didn't
always kick ass
if you're willing to be patient you can
do it second of all if you're willing to
put your ethics aside a little bit
it actually is quite easy to do it helps
so exactly
how would you do this you let's say you
want to be these guys or beat these guys
what does you know you're sam you're
probably one of the most well equipped
people in the world to do this how would
you have gone about it
well what you have to do is you've got
to create multiple brands under one
it's really hard to have one brand and
only a couple products make all this
money
so you'd have to have for us we would
have done and we were going to do this
but then we got bought and the reason i
got bought was a whole different reasons
which is basically i wanted to
um get a payday like and i wanted to i
mean like
i was pretty clear about that before
like i wanted like it was cool
it's awesome i'm gonna stay here but
like it was nice to like
hit get a lot of ticket um but if i
wanted to be patient
and do it for 50 years which
i kind of do to be honest um i would
have created trends but for subset
sub categories and you make the first
newsletter the one that people pay for
only like 49 or 50 bucks and we send you
just a couple things a month and then
the second thing is you go to sub
categories and you charge thousands of
dollars
for example if there was a newsletter
that
uh dissected media companies i work in
the media industry and you told me it
was four thousand dollars and i also got
access to a community
i ain't gonna complain about it right i
mean
i'm gonna do it if there's something for
digital streaming and that you know that
the five analysts are smart
twitch is gonna buy that it's not that
like challenging it's not that hard
right
um and so that's what i would do from
multiple industries
and the thing that a lot of newsletter
writers do which i've talked about those
plenty of times and i don't have to talk
about too much is they do one of two
things
one they charge too little and two if
they charge too little they don't have a
higher end back
back product you need a front end and a
back end so you need your
cheap thing that gets a lot of people
and then you need your paid thing that
gets only a few people but it
makes a lot of money so you guys at
trends is like i don't know 300
something a year
uh you could have been 49 and then
5 000 would have been a better mix of
value
if you are if you were optimizing for
how do we get this thing as profitable
as we can lucrative as you can
yeah and had we not gotten bought i
would have done that i would actually we
were about to change it we were about to
make that change
and by the way what happens to trends
now people still pay for it or it's free
now
um they pay for it we might lower the
price before we were either gonna make
that the back end or we're gonna make
that the front end but we were gonna
copy this model
of a 99 thing and then a two thousand
dollar thing
yeah dude when i see companies like this
it just makes me want to
do it so badly uh because it's like
it just seems so doable now i know that
in practice we're not in by the way
we get we get heat for this sometimes
because we're like dude it's so easy
it's so simple
we're talking like relatively like
building a successful business is hard
okay like it's not
just we're not saying things are easy
sometimes we actually do
say that word easy really what we mean
is simple so like
being able to bench 500 pounds that is
um
um simple like it's straight forward
here's how you get strong in the bench
press you lift a lot and then you eat a
ton
now that is quite hard to do for five
years but that's that was that's the
steps you take so it's like simple
and so what we're saying is that this is
simple it's not yeah actually
i think i think weight loss is actually
a better example because 500 pounds is a
hard thing to bench weight loss is
literally simple where it's like
hey you need to eat these you know avoid
carbs avoid sugars you need to eat a
little bit less less calories than
you're
burning and like you should work out
regularly do
kind of whatever just try to get an hour
a day of you know break a sweat
if you actually just did those two
things and be like hey give it like
four to five months six months boom
you're in great shape everybody knows
that formula
it is actually simple executing it and
doing it having the discipline and
having the rigor to like actually stick
to it
hard but it is way easier
relatively than becoming a crossfit
champion right and so when we're talking
about business
the scale is that it's like it's hard to
create the next facebook
that's really freaking hard uh is it
hard to create a paid community well
i don't think most people who try it
will do it but it's relatively way
easier than creating the next facebook
so
for people that out there that get all
sensitive when we call something easy
it's not we're not trying to mislead you
like yeah it's gonna take work most
likely it won't work it'll take some
time
but we're on a scale of one to spacex
this is more like a one than it is a
spacex and like that's that's a scale
for people to think about
i completely agree and um i think like
now let's talk about what makes this
hard the first and
is that you have to sell your soul a
little bit now
many people will not be comfortable with
this stuff sean is pretty comfortable
with it
i think i'm comfortable with it but i
think i'm a little bit less comfortable
with it you have to be a face
sometimes you have to be you have to say
i'm an expert at
x pay me money to for me to tell you my
thoughts
right second um well no this is off that
so guys like james altucher who we've
had this podcast he was ridiculed for
doing this with bitcoin
everyone made fun of him he made 60
million dollars doing it
but he still got mocked constantly and
shockingly most people would actually
prefer
not to make the money and not get made
fun of than they would to make the money
and get made fun of
well the way i think about it is most
people truly will not
they are afraid that they're gonna get
them not gonna get the money and get
mocked and so they're like [__] it i
won't do it
if you really had a guarantee i think
people would happily
trade reputation points for bank points
well
yeah and perhaps but that's not moot
point because the fact is is that most
people don't even want to
because the first point you said of like
they may not get the money at all that
is also true
and that's what they're they're not
going to do that so you have to do that
second
it's a treadmill you can't stop this is
a lifetime
job so if you're a content creator you i
hired people to do it for me you 100
can do that but you're gonna you can't
you have to you actually have to do the
work for a little while
in the anyway so you're gonna have to
work and by the way uh
quick question on hiring because people
ask me this and i have no idea i'm like
why don't you ask sam
he's the one who did it why are you
asking me they'll be like dude the
hustle has had
amazing talent like they talk about
trung they talk about steph smith
some of the people you guys do me i mean
right i mean i consider
you be part of our crew you me trung
steph it's got colby we've got yeah
we've got a bunch of people so so the
question is
where the heck did you find these people
so can you give me the
10 seconds on each where'd you find
chung where'd you find steph where'd you
find colby where'd you find
you know all these people colby was uh
worked at a pr firm where he was doing
some copywriting work
uh and uh trung uh eamonn
did he just apply to you or you like
recognize like oh this guy's good mutual
connection friend of a friend said you
should talk to this person
uh trung came from eamon troy a mutual
friend and investor of the hustle
steph uh i found on twitter because i
read her blog
who else i'd say i just kind of want to
know and then when you found these
people are you
what's your did you cycle through 30
people who kind of
sort of stopped before you found the
gems when we actually sold
to hubspot they're like wow you guys
have a lot of churn i'm like yeah but
here's what we do
like this is actually quite normal in
the editorial industry but you hire a
bunch of people and you've
got a you you either fire or there's a
mutual like all right we tried it it
wouldn't fit
um and that happens a lot um yeah
and you also when you have to do the
tone i would say that was also a key
right because you were writing it
originally
and so you yeah and you called it
interesting people
you saw the trends community like i was
the one actually doing
every day you were posting in that thing
yeah and that sets the culture and it
attracts like-minded people
um i also think that um once you find
the winners then you go all in on them
so trung
is what i call he's a made man steph a
made woman
whatever steph wants to do something
cool sounds good
what do you need uh when other people
come with an idea
trying to double that number whatever's
number sam gave you time to double it
these guys are all doing great um
whenever
if if an outside person or if a non-made
person comes with an idea it's
you know why don't you just show me a
little mvp and let's see what people
think
if trung says something it's all right
yes sir
right yeah like you're a proven hitmaker
so
and then the um the last thing is when
we interview them i always ask about the
bottom fourth of the resume which is
like the college classes and all the
things that they take because i want
them to like entertain me during the
interview
so in the same way that you are really
good at storytelling you have to have
other people that are good storytelling
right right okay i like it um
can we do one idea real quick before we
we jump so
um this is kind of kind of kind of going
to feel like it's out of left field but
i would say
there's something interesting here so i
light it on the page oh yeah uh so i'm
down here
uh virtual team building so
for a long time people have had this
problem of we have a team we're working
on stuff together
you know as the boss you're you know
sometimes you got to crack the whip and
it feels like it's just task after task
and deadline after deadline and
you want to make sure that this team is
really coming together and is bonded and
you want people to have a good time here
and you don't want them to leave and all
the good all the good things you care
about your people
the experience they have working for you
and so in the old world this was
different team building solutions and so
we would do off-site i don't know what
you did with the hustle crew but like
you know some people go to a shooting
range some people go to an escape room
some people do
like you know um painting and wine
tasting and
whatever you know what i liked most
just like a fancy dinner right yeah
let's go out to dinner right let's go to
a cool place i you know it's on me order
what you want type it yeah i just like
go
we would do like fancy dinners right and
um
and and this is every team literally i
heard a nba coach talking about this the
other day he goes man we got all these
new players so hard with
kovid because in the old days you just
go to the bar you put
your card behind the tab you know and
you say all the drinks are on me tonight
you know go crazy guys he's like he's
like you didn't have to like have
conversations like
you just needed to give guys a night out
together and good things will happen
and um and so with the you know we have
this remote work trend everybody's going
remote
um so how are those teams gonna do it
how are they gonna
do team bonding because although you get
to spend more time with your family and
you get not less time and traffic
commuting
you do lose the water cooler you lose
the team bonding
so how are people going to do this so
i've seen some cool companies popping up
that are doing this and i think they're
doing quite well so i want to point out
a couple
and then get your take on if you think
these are good ideas bad ideas or how
you would do it so
the first couple of team team rock team
rotary is that right yeah team rotary
like camaraderie but for a team and so
this is actually backed by some pretty
legit players like some pretty pretty
famous people in silicon valley
which i'm surprised at because it kind
of just looks like a goofy like they
seem like small bootstrapped ideas but
actually they have some big backing
because
i think people recognize the spaces
companies pay
tens of thousands of dollars per
division a year
to have team bonding and so then you
know in a big company you have
you know easily high six figures low
seven figures worth of spend
on uh on this type of thing that's my
guess uh i'm not in the finance team so
maybe i'm off but
i think that's about right i'm sorry
first of all team rotary
looks interesting horrible name what an
awful
name um they've got a pretty badass uh
a pretty badass set of advisors guys
like heather boy who seems to hate
everything as you've said
uh is on their advisor or their board
pretty interesting yeah exactly so he's
on this and it says trusted by three 300
plus global teams you see pinterest
who's that you don't remember summer
sanders she was from
and uh she was like a swimmer in the 90s
and then was the host of all the
nickelodeon tv shows
no way that's that's hilarious summer
sanders works at product development at
team rotary
so like you know you could do things so
if i click their experiences right i
click the
bond and engage category so it's like
a coffee and tea tasting a wine tasting
a guacamole tasting
a painting class or whatever it could be
if you do kick off
kick team kickoffs uh okay we got our
guacamole tasting again but we also have
the high-heeled shoe project a lesson
for inclusion
um you know so there's these like uh
kind of team experiences lessons in a
box or bonding in a box
experience it so that's one then our
friend from the pod
greg eisenberg created one called nice
break dot fun
um dude this guy loves like
cute names yeah give me give me a name
check how do you feel about nice break
that fun
it's okay it's good he loves like he he
love
greg is like the coolest guy in my
company like public school or like
school works or like school bus
like well his studio is called late
checkout
checkout like you know the grocery store
i remember being like why did you open
this agency late check out it seems like
a weird thing to do like you're an
entrepreneur why are you doing this like
kind of like product design creative
agency thing
and um and then every week he's like
yeah we're like i'll put i'll post a
cool product
that i think is awesome he's like oh
yeah we worked with him we designed the
prototype
i'm like he's doing it for all of them
i'm like oh actually this is [__]
awesome
you're like on the ground floor of all
these things you can invest in them
you're meeting them you're like seeing
all these spaces and getting paid to do
it like
okay that's pretty cool and he's using
that to fund his
own in his own projects they're their
own internal projects which i don't know
that's
that's actually a pretty cool way of
doing it but they have things like a
comedian will do like an improv class
with you guys over zoom or
a virtual escape room or a um
you know a wardrobe makeover or stuff
like that right so i think this is kind
of cool and there's other products like
this that are like just a straight up
zoom escape room it's like eight people
enter one hour goes on the clock
and the whole thing happens in zoom so i
think there's this is going to be
i think a pretty big space that starts
out looking like a toy but ends up being
a pretty
pretty solid business what do you think
yeah i first of all
late checkout.com or sorry uh with
latecheckout.com is greg
it's uh mostly shawn's buddy uh
he's got a community community design
firm
go to that website and look at what he's
doing it's really good
that guy is really good um nice break
fun
nice breakdown fun i think it's cool
they're charging a lot of money which i
think is badass
so they charge two thousand 000 a month
plus
okay so a grand a month gets you two
nice breaks per month
for and that's for companies that are 25
to 50.
if you're okay i understand how this
works uh
yeah this could break this could be a
hit i think this is great
i think this could totally be a hit can
it be a huge vc thing
i don't know but this could make tens of
millions of dollars in the subscriptions
exactly and the other thing is um one
way to think about problems like these
or find
opportunities like these is you go uh in
the c-suite
so you say okay there's a ceo there's a
cmo there's a cto cfo cio whatever right
you go through all of them and we were
laughing because you were like what the
hell is a chro so this is what a chro
thinks about
they're the chief people officer
essentially of a of a company
i kind of use this interchangeably maybe
there's some nuance difference
sorry to you know the three chroes that
listen to this podcast
um i didn't mean to to uh what is the
chr chief
human resources i think uh officers
right so
so they think about the stuff right
they're like okay the whole workforce
has just gone remote
we really care about what's called
employee engagement which just means how
happy are people to work here are they
going to leave are they going to
is this a toxic work environment or not
and so then they have this
do you so one thing you could do is you
go talk to these people
and you just sort of say what sucks
what's what's
keeping you up at night what are you
stressing about and you start to ask
these questions and at first they won't
give you a whole bunch but then you say
all right
can you show me your budget for the year
oh wow you spend a lot of money on you
know
people development what is people
development means and it's like oh
that's corporate training and blah blah
blah
oh interesting who do you guys use for
that you go look up those companies
that is like some people sometimes
people ask like how do you guys think of
these things
that's how we learn these things it's
like we just start to sniff in these
types of ways and you start to learn
about all these spaces that are outside
of just your day-to-day world view
so if you're out there as an
entrepreneur trying to figure out where
can i build a company where there's
i don't want to just guess on demand
this is one way you go talk to somebody
who's in charge you figure out what
their what's
stressing them out what problems they
need solved what language they use when
they describe it
that's your landing page that's your ad
and then you look at their budget and
you see
do the does the money map to the problem
and if the money maps to the problem you
start to see oh okay
and you ask them hey which budget line
item is growing a lot year over year
which which line item was smaller last
year and bigger this year
because that's the space where they're
still looking for new solutions and you
could do that for an individual as well
i think what you can do is you can go
sign up for mint or whatever and just
look at the categories of your
money and just look at the trailing 12
months and be like wait what am i
consistently spending money on
and do that with five or 10 friends and
that's actually a great way to find an
idea
and doing it with businesses is far more
profitable so you just go and you look
at
they're co you look at quickbooks and
you say all right what's going on here
where's all the money going to
right it's an awesome way that's
actually kind of a cool business in
itself which is like
how do i how do i what
like wallet share like how do i just see
how call wallet share
these people are moms in america where
is their wallet going right like what
are they spending their time and money
on i think
you know big brands like i don't know
procter gamble they
they think about this a lot they
interview a ton of moms they say oh okay
you know
the mom controls this much of the
household budget you know 70 percent or
whatever
and then within that every month she's
spending x percent on groceries y
percent on household
cleaners this percent on this 60 on this
and that's how they decide okay we need
to invest our
product development according to where
the budget is
um because that's how that's how we make
our money back that's such an
interesting way to do things like
i guess you could do it how many public
companies there's two thousand public
companies in america
you could easily or i think there's like
four thousand something four thousand
uh however many michael actually said
last episode four thousand let's say
you could easily do that with with all
their
categories right you can't see line
items but you could see like gna
or but you might be that's kind of an
interesting study
right and uh and you can do this with
just media companies how are
media what what does the expenses look
like of a media company
where are they allocating you know where
where are they where do they spend all
their money
and where which which ones are changing
uh over time where is things shifting
and so i think that's kind of like an
interesting signal that you can use at
the company level
one um division in a company an
individual person whatever and i think
you get a lot of insights from that
i think that's a great idea i think what
we just said of like did you make up
that
name wallet share is that a thing uh i
think that's a term
in general um like it's it's a general
term but but
um i've also seen this by the way in
terms of
for in the social networking space in
terms of time
so wechat i think or um one of the
chinese companies
they had this presentation i saw and you
know i'm sitting there trying to go
through a chinese presentation so you
know
maybe someone's lost translation but i
got the general idea which was
they want an app for every minute of
your day because china has all these
like super apps like wechat you can pay
your house bills in it and it's like
whatsapp and you can also like subscribe
to netflix through it
you know their version of netflix but
it's also like you know where you post
photos and something like that
so what they said was like they took a
person's day so they're like okay 15
year old kid wakes up in the morning at
this time
first 10 minutes of the day what what
products are they using what apps are
they using
and they start to break it down minute
by minute basically like
what where are their gaps so today we're
taking up four hours of this person's
time
if they're awake for 12 hours how do we
spend how do we get 12 hours of their
or 16 hours how do we get 16 hours of
mind share from this person
well they watch movies at night we need
an app for movies well during the day
they need
they message their friends we need that
they need news they get the news all
right cool we're going to do news and
that's how they
they think about because how do they
expand if you're an ad based business
you need attention
so how do i get more attention well i
need more hours of the day of yours how
do i get more hours of the day well i
got to figure out how you spend it today
and i got to insert myself there
i have a few friends that have worked on
those on that at facebook where they
were like all right
we have found out that if you put
stickers onto photos people spend like
five seconds more
and they have like 50 people just
working on stickers and i'm just like
kill yourself
uh like these people hated their job
dude one of my best friends
his job at facebook was literally he was
in the you know it was called like
security and
safety and privacy of community or
something like that department and
literally he's like i just try to make
sure a dick doesn't show up on your
facebook feed
he's like so uh he's like you wouldn't
believe how many dicks are posted on
facebook every day he's like have you
ever seen a dick and i was like no never
not one he's like that's right
at least there's that's cool you're like
trying to protect people whatever
that's cool but he's like i'm writing
like he's like i'm reviewing folders of
images that are just being like dick not
a dick dick not a dick right and then
like also
same thing on the algorithm side like we
were writing programs to train the
computer
to recognize this verse that and he's
like it's a cat mass game always
harder than you think they're always one
step ahead
like dimes or sean's d
[Laughter]
no that's just about a dollar in pennies
they uh but yeah i mean at least that
job is all right but
like i can't imagine working at a
facebook or an instagram and just all
i'm trying to do is suck more
of people's time um yeah it is sad when
you think about it like the the best
brains of our generation are
basically sitting inside the giant slot
machine
and being like okay how do we how do we
get the rat to come back again you know
like
how do we get her to come back more and
more and more and spend more time and
more time right
like that's the reality and it's like
hey i get paid 500 000
a year to do this and i get free lunch
and they do my laundry and i get foot
massages on fridays and like
people think i'm joking that's those are
all true things that happen
um before we wrap up did you see that
you were you so you and i are one for
one of being turned into meme so you
posted
something like i'm looking for a meme
creator
500 a month no vacation and uh
you posted all this other funny stuff
and people like mocked you uh
liquidity a bunch of people mocked you
it's pretty great i think
hopefully they realize that like we do
this [__] on purpose
yeah or like it's not even okay like
okay i'd love to say
huh i'm in on the joke i knew this like
yeah i knew it was silly but like
i didn't think anything would turn into
like we know like we're self-aware
enough to know this is like
like mockable i wrote no vacation it's
not even a real job like
of course this is a fake job posting
i'm not fake it's like i'm basically
like just being like hey does someone
want a side hustle for me by making a
bunch of memes
you can make 500 bucks a month just make
me a few memes every week that's really
what i was trying to say but if i say
that
it's only going to get like 100 likes
but if i say it the way i said it over
the top boom i got
thousands of likes and the things spread
and a bunch of people got angry and
literally like taylor lorenz was like
why does this person not get sick leave
because
and so um yeah we're kind of doing this
on purpose but also i am just kind of a
character
and like i don't i'm just saying things
you know as i think them and then i move
on with my life and like
i win either way like i win if if you
get mad i win
if you you know like if you take it
seriously
and um you apply i win like it's i win i
win no matter what as long as i don't
get
completely canceled i win
which might happen one day soon but
we'll have we'll have fun until then
um and i will explain someday why i am
hiring uh a personal
meme god to uh to to do some memes for
me i will explain
you have to explain that why i mean
there's nothing no there's something
there's actually a cool story um there's
actually a cool story around it but
uh it's not quite ready yet the story
will be cooler if i put the whole thing
together
and then explain it when it's uh when
it's ready so that will come in i don't
know a couple months
um and i guess you'll have to share some
of the best ones you got
yes sir um all right that's it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
travel never looking back